There are a ton of observations to make here, and you
might have said something about a particular spike in the graph,
or spoken more generally about the trends. Here's what I noticed,
I noticed that the vertical scale had changed, since the blue line
goes all the way down to the bottom. This means that
the number of times that we see music or movies in
headlines is much greater than the number of times we see
the word chicken. I also noticed that music used to be more
prevalent in headlines, but it's declined in recent
years. In fact, the word movies overtook the word
music for headline presence around June 2010. That
might not have been obvious on the static image.
But if you played with the interactive visualization,
you could find dates and other interesting things too.
If you notice something else that isn't covered
in the solution video, share it on the forum.